all right we're back for another episode
i am absolutely loaded up with
pre-workout right now and trying to
crank out as many of these as possible
so i can upload while i'm on vacation
uh today's episode is going to be about
unreliable clocks in distributed systems
like my dick it is going to be short but
still useful and effective
nonetheless let's get into it okey dokey
unreliable clocks
so in theory imagine you have a database
which has a bunch of leaders right so we
can make a right to each of them and you
know we want to decide how to resolve
conflicts
and in order to resolve these conflicts
we want to know which write came first
between the two well i guess we could do
something like
vector clocks which we've discussed in
the past or rather version vectors
but the issue there is that version
vectors will just say that a lot of
vectors are concurrent and you have to
keep them as siblings but what if we
just want to keep one value well we
would need some way to order our rights
so why don't we just use timestamps like
it doesn't require any extra
synchronization between the machines
everyone has a clock on their computer
and as far as we can tell they're all
pretty accurate right so it should be
pretty easy to do this and get rid of
concurrency bugs in general it seems
like we have a great solution well
actually it's not so simple we can't
rely on clocks i'll explain why right
now
okay let's talk about how clocks
actually work on most computers
unless you are really trying to keep
synchronized with um you know the
current time and you have like a gps
receiver plugged into your computer the
majority of computers will occasionally
synchronize with servers running ntp aka
the network time protocol
once this happens computers will use
something called an internal quartz
clock to measure the elapsed time and
keep the time updated until the next
synchronization with ntp
well that's pretty simple right however
there are some issues to this one
even when i make a call to mtp ntp is
going to give me the current time from
that server however
then that time has to come back to me
over the network and the network can
take an arbitrary amount of time so now
i have an outdated ntp result
additionally we have something called
quartz clock drift which is pretty bad
it means that the quartz clock running
in our computers
actually is able to oscillate a little
bit more or less frequently sometimes in
fact i believe using google's
measurement they average that um
one day without synchronizing with ntp
leads to seven seconds of clock skew
which is actually pretty significant you
know like if i make a right and then
someone else five seconds later makes
their right if my clock is off by seven
seconds the server might think they're
right was actually earlier than that
and then furthermore you know if we're
using client time stamps we can't set
the clock of a device we don't own a lot
of people if you've ever just like been
on an iphone have gotten around like
certain gaming time requirements by
literally changing the time on their
phone and then boom bug fixed so
okay how would we measure elapsed time
then well we definitely shouldn't use
the time of day clock on our computer
why because if we synchronize with ntp
and our current clock is kind of far off
from it we might literally jump around
and then it's going to completely throw
off the elapsed time additionally
there's these stupid things called leap
seconds where minutes either have 59 or
61 seconds i don't really know about it
no one really knows about it except
their time experts but the point is it
ignores them so when this happens it
also makes it bad for elapsed time
as a result instead we should really
just be using a monotonic clock a
monotonic clock is basically just a
counter on a computer that goes up a
second at a time and that way you can
easily see how many elapsed seconds
there were between two events happening
additionally ordering events like i said
this was kind of the main motivation
behind using timestamps and distributed
computing was that we want to say what
happened first and use the timestamps to
do so however as i've discussed these
clocks are unreliable so we shouldn't be
doing this
it can result in just dropping data if
you're using last right wins and you
have one right
like i said that happens on you know my
server and then another write on the
server in china but their clocks are out
of sync my right might have happened
before but it seems like the right in
china happened first so boom my data's
just gone and i never even know why so
data dropped
um
so instead what we should do is use
logical timestamps so that's something
like either version vectors or if you
really want a complete ordering of
things in order to uh to decide
conflicts something like lan port
timestamps which i'll discuss in a
subsequent video
okay summary i told you this one was
quick
in distributed systems clocks really are
not reliable they can really only just
generate a confidence interval that it
is currently between some minimum time
and some maximum time
and even though that confidence interval
is solid if we're synchronizing with ntp
really frequently
at the end of the day there is a
possibility of introducing a lot of
time-based bugs there and it's really
not an ideal solution
there are still a lot of companies that
rely on using timestamps for their
databases and people do that all the
time one of the most popular nosql key
value stores is cassandra which goes and
resolves
conflicts by using timestamp and they
basically acknowledge you should try and
keep your servers as synchronized with
ntp as possible
another option that people use is google
spanner where google spanner really
heavily relies on timing however the one
thing they do is use specialized
hardware where all of their servers have
a gps clock attached to them so they can
stay as confident about their time
interval as possible and as a result
they're able to take consistent
snapshots using time intervals
but even still at the end of the day is
this the best possible solution probably
not it's pretty complex and it
introduces a lot of
you know issues to the problem so at the
end of the day
we would rather be using a different
ordering mechanism and i'll start
discussing those in subsequent